[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
SHUBHIKIA TANEJA:
Hello everyone.
Welcome to A Year
in GCP Networking.
I'm Shubhikia Taneja, and I'm a
product marketing manager here
at Google Cloud.
I have with me Zach Selis,
who is a networking specialist
customer engineer.
And we are also thrilled to
have Nick Jacques joining us
from one of the leading
US retailers, Target.
Nick is a lead
engineer at Target,
and he'll be sharing with
us how Target uses GCP,
with an emphasis on networking
products and services.
So with that, let's get started.
We'll also leave a few minutes
of live Q&A in the end.
In case your questions
don't get answered, please
feel free to use
Dorie in your apps.
That will be open
throughout the week,
and we'll continue answering
questions over there.
And lastly, these
conferences bring a big crowd
all under the same roof, and
we love to hear back from you.
This session is an early series.
So please spend a
couple of minutes
giving us a survey in the
end, so that we can continue
to improve our content.
So Newton gave us
three laws of motion.
If there were an equal
in three laws of cloud,
networking would
be one of those.
Because without the
network, there is no cloud.
You might be wondering,
why am I opening
this session with this slide?
It is because it's the emphasis
on the infrastructure that
has let Google scale
the way we have,
which is depicted by
our own cloud services
that you see here--
eight different apps with
a billion users each.
One of the core
differentiators that acts
as a fundamental backbone of
these apps is our network.
And at GCP, our goal has been
to give access to our customers
to the same network.
Now let's look at some of the
global infrastructure numbers
around the world, which is very
important for the customer.
We have 19 regions
that are live today.
We will be launching new regions
in Jakarta, Indonesia, Osaka,
Japan.
And if you saw the
keynote this morning,
Sundar announced
two more regions
in Seoul and Salt Lake City.
We also have 134 POPs,
or points of presence.
These are the points
where the traffic
is exchanged between
Google's network
and the public internet.
It shouldn't come as a surprise.
We have 30 renewable
energy project locations.
We match 100% of
the energy that we
consume with renewable energy,
to maintain our commitment
to being carbon neutral.
Nine years ago, Google became
the first major non-telco
to invest in sub sea cables.
We have had 13 sub sea cable
investments since then,
including two private cables
that were announced last year.
So the key takeaway here
is that these numbers
continue to grow between what
you saw last year and today.
And the infrastructure
helps our customers
deliver their services
closer to their users.
Now when you think about the
networking product portfolio,
there are two elements I
want you to think about.
The first one is
the infrastructure
that you just got
a sneak peek into,
and this is something that
our customers get by default
when they move to Google Cloud.
The second piece is our
products and services
that the customers can consume.
There are over 20
products in our portfolio.
Not everything is
shown over here.
Zach and I will walk you
through the advancements
that we have made across these
products, which can be broadly
broken down into five pillars--
connect, scale, optimize,
secure, and modernize.
In the interest
of time, we won't
be able to cover the
advancements made
in the last one year across
each and every advancement.
But our goal from
this session is
for you to walk away with
a fundamental understanding
of our products,
so that then you
can pick deep dive sessions
for specific products
that you are interested in
learning more over the next two
days.
So with that let's get
started with Connect.
Our goal here is to ensure that
we are enabling our customers
to connect to Google
Cloud on their terms,
which means offering
hybrid connectivity
options, flexible hybrid
connectivity options.
We offer Cloud Interconnect,
which comes in two flavors--
dedicated interconnect
and partner interconnect.
If you can meet Google at one
of our 81 dedicated interconnect
locations, you can opt for that.
Or if you cannot meet us there
or you prefer to work with
a partner, you can opt
for partner interconnect.
Both the options offer
flexible bandwidth
between 50 meg and 10 gig,
an industry leading SLA
is of four nines of uptime.
We also offer cloud VPN for
lower bandwidth requirements
and lower cost.
Both cloud interconnect
and cloud VPN
are coming up with
interesting announcements
to model, so stay
tuned for that.
The last option is
peering, which you can also
use to connect to Google Cloud.
Now over the past one year, we
have added several new partners
for partner interconnect, so
I'm sure you saw something
like this last year in
this session as well.
We continue to add more
partners to our ecosystem.
Currently we have
over 50 partners
that can help our customers
get onramped to Google Cloud.
Next, on the connect pillar,
let's talk about VPC.
First of all, what is VPC?
VPC stands for
virtual private cloud.
It is your own piece of
logically isolated and secure
Google Cloud.
It resembles the
traditional network,
but with the benefits of
scalable infrastructure.
Now, what's unique
about our global
VPC is that it uses
the same backbone
that we have built
for our own products,
like Google Search, YouTube,
that you saw earlier.
And that enables our
customers to create VMs
anywhere in the world,
across any of our 19 regions,
and have private connectivity
between them by default.
So the customers
don't need to set up
any VPN connections,
or peering connections,
or give their VMs external IDs.
This reduces the toil
of sprawl and config,
and truly enables our
customers to have global access
to their workloads.
And that's what we mean when
we say 19 regions, one VPC.
Now on VPC, we have announced
two key advancements
in the last one year.
The first one is private
access for GCP services.
This is a new framework that
provides private connectivity
between your VPC
network and the service
that you're communicating to.
Cloud SQL is the force GCP
service to use this framework.
The VM instances
in your VPC network
and the service
that you are talking
to communicate via the
internal RFC 1918 IP addresses.
And once you set up
this connectivity,
any number of GCP services
can use that connection.
So again, to
summarize, it reduces
these toil of management and
set up to talk to GCP services.
The second advancement that
we have made on the VPC side
is the private Google
access for on-prem.
This enables your
on-prem hosts to reach
Google APIs and services through
a cloud VPN tunnel, or a Cloud
Interconnect connection.
So you can leverage your
existing private connection
to Google Cloud for
this, and that also
means that you can take
advantage of VPC service
controls that Zach
will cover later.
It does not require
your on-prem hosts
to have external IP addresses.
Next on the Connect
pillar, I want
to talk about the Cloud DNS.
We have added two
capabilities on Cloud DNS
in the last one year.
First one is private
zones, and the second one
is DNS forwarding.
Private zones provides a
simple to manage, internal DNS
solution, for your
private networks on GCP.
This removes basically
the need to provision
and manage any
additional resources,
or compute resources,
simplifying management
for networking administrators.
Now, as you can see
in this animation,
the DNS queries for private
zones, myenterprise.com,
it'll just show
up, are restricted
to your internal network.
And any DNS queries will
that from the hostile agent
on the right, from
public internet,
get denied, because this
is a private network.
Now, a key part of a successful
hybrid cloud strategy
is that you should be able to
find your resources easily,
whether they are
on-prem or on cloud.
DNS forwarding lets you
link your on-prem and cloud
environments easily.
You can set up bi-directional
forwarding zones
between your on-prem
name servers,
and GCP's internal name service.
As you can see in the animation,
on the outbound forwarding,
it lets your GCP resources
use your existing on-prem DNS
servers, and on the
inbound forwarding
it lets you are on-prem
resources use the Cloud
DNS to resolve domains.
With that, we wrap up
the connect pillar,
and we are now going
to move to optimize.
The G8 network service
tiers years last month.
Some of you may have seen that
announcement come through.
Network service tiers
lets our customers
customize the
underlying network,
and basically optimize it
for performance or cost.
So if you are using
Google Cloud today,
you're most likely using
our premium tier network.
The premium tier
delivers traffic
over Google's well-provisioned,
low latency, highly reliable
global network,
which we saw earlier.
But for some key
cases, customers
may prefer a
standard tier, which
is a cheaper, lower
performance alternative,
but it is still
comparable in performance
to other public clouds.
Most cloud providers use
what is called hot potato
routing, which you
see on the bottom
here, which means when
you try to send traffic
on their network
it gets offloaded
to the public internet
as soon as possible.
Whereas, we use
cold potato routing,
that you see on the top.
We keep that traffic on
Google's private network
for as long as
possible, and it usually
exits the public internet as
close as possible to the end
user, usually in the
same city or town.
And that enables us to provide
better reliability, higher
security, and
higher performance.
Cedexis, an internet performance
monitoring and optimizations
tools company, which
is now part of Citrix,
did some performance
comparisons.
And as expected, the premium
tier is 1.7x times faster than
the standard tier.
So on the top is the throughput
from the premium tier
in green, which is what you get
from our premium tier network.
And on the bottom, in the
blue, is the standard deal
throughput, which is what you
get from our standard deal,
and most other public clouds.
And you can get
these numbers online
on the website of Cedexis.
So that wraps up optimize.
I would next like to move
into the scale pillar, which
includes cloud load
balancing and cloud CDN.
Before we talk about the
different advancements
that we have made in
cloud load balancing,
I would first like to talk about
how Google does global load
balancing.
Load balancers and most other
public clouds are regional,
so that means you have a single
whip or virtual IP per region.
And then you have backend
instances in those regions,
as well.
Now, regions are silos, so the
load balancer in one region
can not use the capacity of
load balancer in another region.
Whereas with Google
global load balancing,
you can have your application
instances running anywhere
in the world, across
any of our 19 regions,
but you'll get a single
whip or virtual IP
to frontend all those
backend instances.
So, that way, the customers
get full global capacity
and cross region fail over.
It's also closely tied
to the autoscaler that
scales up or down your
backend instances based
on inline traffic.
So, as you can see, this
again helps our customers
deliver their services
closer to their end users,
and scale up or down
in line with traffic.
With that, let's take a look
at some of the advancements
that we have made on
our load balancers.
We offer five different
flavors of load balancers,
and there are a
lot of capabilities
that we have announced across
these different flavors
over the last one year.
I won't have the time to
go cover all of those.
There is a deep dive session
on our load balanceres tomorrow
if you are interested
in more details.
I have just
handpicked a few here.
On our internal load
balancer, we now
support all ports, which
basically takes away
the earlier requirement
of five ports.
Very useful for users who
want to manage multiple layers
for applications.
Also the internal
load balancer now
reduces the management
and the config setup,
by supporting DNS based
service discovery.
On the HTTP(S) load
balancer front,
we now support user defined
request headers, which
basically insert client
information, the geolocation,
or the RTT, and then send
it to the backend instances.
And lastly, in order to
continue our commitment
of making the internet faster,
on the HTTP(S) load balancer,
we support the quick and
the HTTP/2 protocols.
So if your applications
are latency sensitive,
they're going to see
a boost of performance
as a result of that integration.
On the Google Cloud
CDM, last year
we went [INAUDIBLE] with
large object support,
allowing you to cache and
serve video and other content
up to five terabytes in size.
So with that, I talked about
connect, optimize, and scale
pillars.
And I would like to
invite Zach to talk
about secure and
modernized pillars next.
ZACH SELIS: Rebecca.
Let's jump right into
the secure pillar.
We have a number of key
advancements over the last 12
months that I want
to cover today.
So historically, when you wanted
to store your sensitive data
inside of a Google
Cloud managed service,
you had a set of
credentials that
were tied to an IAM role,
that actually determined
whether or not a user
could access that data.
So for example, if
you're storing your data
in Google Cloud
Storage, access control
is merely dictated by which
roles a particular user
or a set of credentials have.
This could open up
your organization
to some weaknesses.
For example, what if IAM
roles are misconfigured,
providing more access
than you intended?
What if those IAM
credentials are compromised?
They are maybe leaked
publicly, or somehow
get into the hands
of somebody who's
not supposed to have them.
And lastly, what if
you have an instance,
a virtual machine inside of
your environment, that gets
compromised, and
somebody leverages
that compromised instance
to try and exfiltrate data
from your VPC environment?
In addition to this,
traditional network controls,
so access lists that
are restricting access,
based on IP addresses
and protocols,
don't provide
complete protection,
because most Google
services are exposed
from an accessibility
perspective
over the same infrastructure,
leveraging the same protocols.
As you've experienced
when you're
accessing our APIs across a
number of Google products,
it's almost always TLS
encrypted HTTP traffic.
So just relying on
the network controls
themselves didn't provide
enough protections.
To solve this problem, we
developed VPC Service Controls.
This is now available.
It was released in
the last 12 months.
VPC Service Controls
provide you with the ability
to actually permit or deny,
on a per project basis,
access to Google managed
service APIs, based
on the origin of the request.
So this, in combination
with the proper credentials,
and the network access controls,
allow you to basically define
an explicit security
perimeter around your projects
and networks inside
of Google Cloud,
across which data
cannot transfer.
So for example, if
your intended policy
is that you want to create a
Google Cloud Storage bucket,
and store your data in that
bucket inside of a project,
but you don't want to allow
access from the public internet
to that bucket, you can do
that with VPC service controls,
even if those users
on the internet
have the right credentials.
So VPC service controls
is very powerful.
Provides you with
API level controls
to add the origin of the
request to the existing
suite of controls,
to control access
to data that you store inside
of Google's managed services.
Next we have Cloud
Armor Cloud Armor
allows you to protect
your internet facing,
load balanced workloads,
inside of Google Cloud.
This includes protecting you
from a variety of distributed
denial of service attacks.
And this leverages
the same protections
that Google has developed
over the past 20 years
to make sure that
our own services--
Drive, Gmail,
Search, et cetera--
remain available and
scalable on a global basis.
Cloud Armor is integrated with
Google Cloud load balancing,
and provides you the ability
to implement these controls
at the edge of Google's network.
So when Shubhikia talked
about our global backbone
and leveraging our premium
network where your users come
on to Google's network as
close to the user as possible,
Cloud Armor allows you to
implement controls to determine
from both layer seven--
sorry, layer three,
so traditional network
controls, all the way
through Layer seven,
what users are able to access
your load balanced workloads.
So Cloud Armor is available
now publicly as well.
Next, we have Cloud NAT.
This was probably one of the
most frequently requested
capabilities from customers,
and we've made this available
now in the last 12 months.
Traditionally when you deploy
resources, applications,
virtual machines
inside of the cloud,
you want to protect those
systems from direct access
from the public internet
at the same time.
Yep.
So Cloud NAT solves
this problem for you
by implementing a
regional cloud NAT
gateway that allows
you to control access,
outbound access, from
those virtual machines
or your applications, in an
efficient manner on a per
region basis.
There are a number of key
benefits to our Cloud NAT
implementation.
First, it's a completely
software driven, distributed
implementation.
So the actual NAT
capabilities are
built into the fabric
of the VPC itself.
So there's no
device that you have
to force traffic through
from an app perspective.
There's no risk of potential
choke points from a performance
perspective, because it's a
completely distributed system.
Second, we give you the control
over whether Google manages
the public IP addresses, as you
scale up and down the number
of translations that need to
happen for traffic destined
to the internet, or
whether you explicitly
define through static
IP reservations
in your projects, which public
IP addresses are associated
with NAT.
The latter case
being very common,
for example, if
you're establishing
outbound connections
to partners,
and those partners need
to whitelist the source
IP addresses that
you're coming from.
You have a configuration
choice there.
Google can manage those
addresses for you,
or you can specify through
static reservations which
public IP addresses your
services present themselves
as on the public internet.
And finally, a single
cloud NAT gateway
can support an entire
region, regardless of scale.
So if you have 100 virtual
machines in a region
if you have 15,000 virtual
machines in a region,
irrespective of
the number of VMs,
irrespective of the
volume of traffic
that's going out
towards the internet,
from that particular region you
only need a single cloud NAT
gateway.
And again this goes
back to the uniqueness
and the architecture, and the
distributed way in which we
implement these capabilities.
Cloud NAT is the third key
capability in the secure pillar
that we want to
talk about today.
Next we have Google-managed
certificates.
So Google has a history of
leveraging TLS encryption
whenever possible.
If you remember
several years ago,
we actually let the
ability for websites
who are using HTTPS to
improve their search result
rankings, right?
So you're using encrypted
transport on the internet.
That actually influences
search page results.
At the same time, we also made
the Chrome browser explicitly
kind of identify when websites
were not using TLS, changing
the standard
expectation of users
to assume that all
websites should be using
TLS encryption, and visually,
actually identifying,
when websites do not.
So really kind of changing
the approach there.
At the same time within
Cloud, We're constantly
trying to make things easier for
customers to deploy and manage,
and for this we have made
available in the last year
Google-managed certificates.
So with Google-managed
certificates,
when you create an internet
facing HTTPS load balancer,
as part of that
provisioning you can
select to have Google
automatically procure
and configure the
certificate for the domains
that are supporting that
particular load balancer
instance.
In addition, this
capability automatically
handles certificate renewal
when required, and will
automatically revoke
the certificates when
you delete the load balancer.
So this now allows you to
basically have complete hands
off TLS implementation
for your internet
facing load balancers through
Google-managed certificates.
In addition, regardless of
how you host your backends,
whether those are on
compute instance VMs,
or backed from a workload
perspective on Kubernetes pods,
both types are supported
with this capability.
So really making kind of
the default stance of TLS
encrypted, load balancing,
very easy for you
to manage and deploy.
The next two capabilities
fall under the area
we consider to be
network telemetry.
And the first one is
called VPC flow logs.
So having visibility,
obviously, to traffic inside
of the cloud network, is a
common request of customers.
This is something that I think
customers have kind of become
accustomed to in their on
premise network environments.
And so for traffic that's
traversing your VPC
inside of Google Cloud, whether
it stays solely within the VPC,
say between different virtual
machines inside of Google
Cloud, or whether it's virtual
machines that are talking
to resources out on
the public internet,
you can now enable VPC flow logs
to get identifying information
about that traffic
streamed and to sack driver
from a visibility perspective.
So if you have a
background in networking,
this is pretty
analogous to NetFlow
from your on-prem networking,
with some really great
additional features.
Namely that, not only do we
actually sample the traffic
to determine the
traditional network
information from that traffic--
so source and destination
IP addresses, what protocols
are used, what ports--
we then annotate that
information with more,
I'll say, human
friendly information.
So we add the
project information,
the actual virtual machine
instance names, the VPC
that that instance
is deployed in,
and if the communication
is actually
from an instance
of virtual machine
inside of your VPC to
the public internet,
we ll annotate those
logs to tell you
the geographic information of
what they're talking to so.
You're talking to
an endpoint that
may be in Sao Paolo,
Brazil, as an example.
So these annotations
allow us to basically add
additional information
that we know about the flow
to those flow records.
This information is
streamed natively by default
to stack Stackdriver Logging.
You can also stream it into
BigQuery for analytics.
Or if you're using your own
on premise or external logging
analytics capabilities, you
can actually stream the logs
to those through Cloud Pub/Sub.
So pretty powerful
capability here.
In a similar fashion, we've also
released in the last 12 months
logging for native VPC firewall.
So you can now enable on a
per VPC firewall rule basis
the ability to enable logging.
So as traffic comes
through the VPC
and matches these
firewall rules,
we'll generate logs in
a very similar manner
that we do for VPC flow logging.
So you now have the ability
from a compliance perspective,
as an example, to
actually prove to auditors
that you're blocking
traffic that you
say you're going to block.
This is like VPC flow
logs, available natively
for streaming into stack
Stackdriver Logging.
Again also with BigQuery,
or two external systems
through Cloud Pub/Sub.
So two things with
network telemetry
to give you better visibility
into the cloud network
environment for both traffic
flowing across your VPC,
but also for traffic flowing
to the native VPC firewall.
So those are some of
the key capabilities
from a secure perspective.
Now moving on to modernize.
We're going to talk specifically
here about Google Kubernetes
Engine, and some stuff that
we're doing around Istio.
So Google Kubernetes Engine,
if you're not familiar,
is Google's managed
instance of Kubernetes,
which is our production
ready solution for deploying
containerized applications.
Over the past year,
we've implemented
a number of
capabilities that allow
us to more tightly integrate GKE
clusters with the best of cloud
native networking
inside of Google Cloud.
So the power that we have in
terms of global reach around
our VPCs, as well as the native
high performance routing,
that's now integrated directly
into Google Kubernetes Engine.
And we do this through something
we call VPC native clusters,
which basically takes the
networking that is typically
implemented as an overlay
inside of Kubernetes,
and actually makes
that a fundamental part
of the underlying VPC network.
So this is good not
only from a visibility
and from a routing perspective,
because we now for example
treat pods and
services the same way
we treat virtual machines from
a reachability perspective.
But it also improves
the security,
where we have strong kind
of anti spoofing measures
that are deployed inside of
the network, that are natively
integrated inside of GKE.
This provides
additional capabilities
when we look at
integrating networking
into your on premise
environments,
or hybrid networking.
Because again, capabilities that
are enabled as part of your VPC
from a routing and
visibility perspective
are also now available for
your Kubernetes clusters.
So very powerful capabilities
with respect to GKE.
Also for GKE we've
released something
called Container-native
load balancing.
This is currently in beta.
So in the past, when a load
balancer, like an external load
balancer, like our Google
Cloud load balancer,
targeted resources inside
of a Kubernetes cluster,
you'd have a situation somewhat
similar to this, right?
You have multiple nodes inside
of your Kubernetes cluster.
The load balancer actually
targets the nodes,
or the virtual
machine instances,
as the backends for those
for the load balancer.
Now on those nodes, you may
have a disproportionate number
of pods in Kubernetes.
You could even have a situation
where some of those nodes
don't actually have
the pods that you're
targeting from the load
balancing perspective scheduled
on that node.
And in that case, IP tables, or
kube-proxy, on those Kubernetes
nodes, was responsible for a
second level of load balancing.
So the external
load balancer gets
the traffic to the node, IP
tables, or kube-proxy inside
of Kubernetes, is
responsible for then getting
the traffic to the
direct pod that you're
trying to communicate with.
This is commonly known in
the Kubernetes community
as a double hop problem.
You basically have two
layers of load balancing.
This is especially
problematic if you
look at something like a
regional Kubernetes cluster,
where you have the actual nodes
for the GKE cluster spread
across multiple zones
inside the region.
The external load balancer
could send that traffic
to a node in zone
A, as an example.
And IP tables in
that node in zone A
could then decide it's
going to actually load
balanced that traffic
to a pod that's
running on a node inside of
Zone B, or C, or D, right?
So that second layer
of load balancing
can add not only higher latency,
but for a regional cluster
it can add additional
costs, because you're
paying for the traffic that
goes between the different zones
inside of a region.
So now with container native
load balancing we've internet.
We've introduced something
called network endpoint groups.
And essentially here,
what we're doing
is we're allowing the
pods to basically behave
as if they're virtual machines
from a networking perspective,
inside of the VPC.
So instead of the
Kubernetes nodes actually
being the target of
the load balancer,
it's in fact the
pods themselves that
are the direct target of
the external load balancer.
So when traffic comes
in from your users
to our external load
balancer, the load balancer
looks at not the backends
from a node perspective
inside of Kubernetes.
It actually sends the traffic
directly to the Kubernetes
pods themselves.
So you remove essentially the
second half of load balancing.
This improves latency and
can actually reduce costs
for traffic going between zones
inside of a regional cluster.
So container native load
balancing, very powerful
as well.
Also for GKE, we've actually
provided the ability now
to integrate the load
balancing capabilities in GKE
with some of our cloud
native capabilities,
particularly with our content
delivery network, Cloud
CDN, Identity Aware Proxy,
IAP, and Cloud Armor,
which I talked about
a few slides ago.
Now you can configure and
tune these capabilities
directly from within Kubernetes
manifest or configuration
files.
And the way we do this is with
a concept called BackendConfig.
You use BackendConfig
to configure
these native services, so CDN,
IAP, Cloud Armor, et cetera.
Independent of
Kubernetes ingress,
which defines the web based
load balancer, or services.
So you don't have to keep
overloading the existing
Kubernetes constructs with
annotation and other things
that need to be approved by the
broader Kubernetes community
to integrate with Google
Cloud native capabilities.
So with BackendConfig
you now have the ability
to specify, independently
of ingress and services,
integration with these
native Google Cloud Services.
And then you pair those
two things together.
So for example, an external web
based load balancer that you
may have established,
you may instantiate it
as a Kubernetes ingress, can
now also integrate natively
with Cloud CDN, can now also
integrate natively with IAP,
and can now also integrate
natively with Cloud Armor.
So very powerful capabilities
from a Kubernetes perspective.
Now moving on to Istio.
So if you haven't
heard about Istio,
which I imagine
most of you have,
Istio is an open
source service mesh.
It's heavily inspired by a lot
of internal systems at Google,
but it is developed
in collaboration
with a number of
external partners,
including IBM and Lyft,
the ride sharing company,
from a open source perspective.
It essentially
provides a way for you
to build a service mesh between
your different microservices
that includes load
balancing, that
includes very fine grained
telemetry and monitoring
capabilities, and also allows
you to implement service
to service network
based authentication.
So mutual TLS
authentication, and allows
you to do all of these
things transparently,
without making any
code changes directly
to your application code.
So it essentially provides
an ability for you
to abstract away all of
these common capabilities
in the cloud environment,
without having
to repetitively implement these
in terms of your application
code.
Now what we've released
in the last year is,
you can now with a single click,
or a single flag in the CLI,
you can actually provision
Istio as add-on on
for your GKE clusters.
When you do this,
what happens is,
we automatically deploy
the Istio control plane.
The Istio control plane is made
up of a number of services.
Pilot, which handles the
actual traffic policies
for which traffic goes where,
Mixer, which handles telemetry,
the visibility we talked
about, and policy controls.
And Citadel, which handles
automatic certificate
provisioning and revocation.
All these together are
deployed in your GKE cluster.
And not only are they
deployed with one click,
but for the ongoing upgrade
life of those control plane
services, we
automatically handle
the upgrades for those as well.
This again is part of the
add-on capabilities with GKE.
And with that, I'd
like to welcome up
Nick Jacques from
Target, to talk
about how Target is leveraging
some of these capabilities.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK JACQUES: Right.
Thanks, Zach.
Really glad to be here.
My name is Nick Jacques.
I am a lead engineer
at Target, and I work
on our cloud platform team.
My team is responsible
for building, managing,
and operating the
infrastructure and the platform
that our application teams
at Target deploy on top of.
So if you're not familiar with
Target, just a brief refresher.
We're a nationwide retailer.
We have over 1,800 stores.
At last count, I
think it's 1,845.
39 distribution centers, and
over 350,000 team members.
We have headquarters
locations across the US,
but notably in Minneapolis,
and in the Bay Area here.
And we currently rank number
39 on the Fortune 500.
In addition to all of our
stores and physical locations,
we have target.com
and our mobile apps.
Now, in terms of
virtual square feet,
target.com is our biggest store.
It's visited by 100
million guests per month,
and is currently the fourth most
visited retail site in the US.
When people think
Target, a lot of people
tend to think of traditional
brick and mortar retail.
However, in the last
few years, we've
really become a
technology company
that enables our retail presence
both online and in-store.
And so I'm really excited to
share some of that technology
that we're using and we put
into place with you today.
Where I want to start is
what Target runs on, GCP.
Now, when we talk
about our website,
there's a really
big component to it
that we refer to
as non-commerce.
And this basically is about
73% of our GCP footprint.
Non-commerce is
browsing, searching,
looking at product
information, images, reviews,
and activities of that nature.
We then have commerce.
Now, commerce, as
the name implies,
is adding items to your
cart, checking out,
using a payment method like
a credit card, and so on.
This represents about 27% of
our total footprint in GCP.
And this is a segment
that is subject
to regulatory compliance, so
security is extremely important
here.
We also have our developer
portal hosted on GCP.
So this is where we host
documentation for our APIs,
as well as self-service
mechanisms,
to renew your API keys
and things of that nature.
And we host static content.
So think of JavaScript, and
images, and things like that,
that we can put in GCS
and host there, and not
need to run compute in order
to present that to our guests.
Next what I want to
do is just run you
through some very,
very high level
architecture of how
we're deployed in GCP,
and how things work.
So this is our
non-commerce architecture.
We migrated this
into GCP in 2017
from another cloud provider.
The entire point
of this environment
is, it's a general purpose,
general tenancy environment.
And we use a model that Google
refers to as standalone VPC.
So we have three of these
large, monolithic projects.
They're broken up
per environment.
We have a lab project,
a non-prod project,
and a production project.
And we're I'll start with this,
if you take a look in the lower
right hand corner, is our
data center connectivity.
Today, we use Cloud VPN
to attach our data centers
to GCP, and specifically
to a set of subnets
that we refer to as
platform services.
In our platform
services subnet, we
operate as the name
somewhat implies, services
that are common across
all of the cloud providers
that we operate in.
So for example, we operate
service discovery, secrets
management, data persistence
through Cassandra,
and message queuing via Kafka.
These services can
communicate directly
with our data center for
replication purposes.
Up next, we have our
application hosting
environment, which is on top.
Now again, this is a
general tenancy environment.
But what's interesting
here is, this
is non routeable to
our data centers.
So if our applications need
to communicate with our data
centers, they actually
do so indirectly
through the platform services
that we provide to them.
The interesting piece of this
is this means our application
hosting subnets our air
gapped from our data centers,
so that's a little advantageous
in terms of security.
Finally in the upper
right, what happens
when we have calls that
come in from the internet,
they actually
traverse CDN provider,
and then go to the
appropriate load balancer.
Now, next up is our
commerce architecture.
We migrated this in
2018, last summer.
And we migrated this
from a colo facility.
This environment has
one primary purpose,
and that is to
host workloads that
are subject to
regulatory compliance,
or have high data
security classifications.
This requires really strong
isolation and segmentation
between everything
that runs up there.
As I change slides, you might
have noticed a subtle but very,
very important difference,
and that is we're
using shared VPC in
this environment.
So I mentioned non-commerce
uses three monolithic projects.
In commerce, we
actually use 56 projects
across all of our environments
to construct our architecture.
What we've done is
we've partitioned out
all of our applications and
all of our platform services
into their own
individual subnets,
with their own individual
service projects.
For data center connectivity,
we're now currently using
partner interconnect, and in
another interesting divergence
here, our applications
can connect directly
to our data center workloads.
This is particularly
important because we
run some applications that need
to have synchronous callbacks
to our data centers in
order to complete things
like transactions, when
you're checking out.
Otherwise, beyond all
of the segmentation,
the platform services
that we operate
are the same, and
the applications
that we host are generally
operating in the same way.
We use Compute Engine, and
we use HTTPS load balancers.
Our ingress traffic
comes through a CDM,
just like non-commerce.
So let's look at a
few common pieces.
The first one that
I want to touch on
is the fact that we use
layer seven HTTPS load
balancers in almost all cases.
In fact, in over 99% of our
load balancer use cases,
we use these.
We use Cloud Armor
and SSL policies,
which I'll touch on a little
bit later, to secure our edge.
In our platform
services environment,
we operate proxies and Nats.
Now this is important because
our instances, by and large,
don't have public
IP addresses, but we
need a way for these instances
to reach out to the internet,
to hit third party
APIs, to do things
like address
validation for example.
So we operate proxies, and Nats.
And we install
inspection software that
can police traffic on these.
And we emit those logs to our
on premise SIEM for analysis.
We use firewall rules in
all of our environments.
But we take an
interesting approach
with these in our
commerce environment.
We use firewall rules that
are based on service accounts,
as both sources and targets.
And this helps us achieve a
level of micro segmentation
when it comes to network
connectivity that's allowed.
We use private connectivity
in all of our scenarios,
and I'll touch on specifics
about private connectivity
a little later on.
We use Stackdriver
logging and monitoring
pretty heavily, Cloud DNS
for both public and private
authoritative record
resolution, and we
use Cloud Pub/Sub as a way
to move traffic between GCP
and our on premise data centers.
So I went through all
of that to give you
a little context for
these next few items
that I want to discuss with you.
The first one is VPC
Service Controls.
Now Zach already
went through a lot
of the fine details of
VPC Service Controls
so I'm just going to talk
to you about a Target use
case for you.
What you see on the
screen is a grouping
of our commerce projects.
And you also see some of
our non-commerce projects.
Now, we basically have
dozens of projects,
and these have varying different
levels of data security
classifications.
They also may have varying
levels of regulatory compliance
that are required.
What we don't want to
do in these situations
are cross logical boundaries.
But the problem is,
earlier on, last year,
these were more
imaginary boundaries,
defined by Target policy,
and not anything concrete.
So for example, if you had the
appropriate service account
credentials, you
could, for example,
reach from our
commerce environment
into our non-commerce
environment,
look at some stuff that's in the
storage there, or vise versa.
Now we don't allow
this by policy,
but there isn't an actual
way to prevent this.
So what can we do to prevent
this type of activity?
Well, we can use VPC
Service Controls,
and we can draw a perimeter
around the projects
that all have the same
data classification.
So in this example, we draw this
around our commerce project.
What we do then is
we disable API access
that crosses this perimeter.
So this denies the access across
the perimeter, both inside
and out, and helps us prevent
crossing between different data
classifications.
There's another really big
benefit here, and that is,
what happens if a third party
suddenly becomes involved,
and you're worried
about data exfiltration?
Now, this is basically a
nightmare scenario for you.
You don't want people
to exfiltrate data.
And the problem is, once
data has been exfiltrated,
you really can't put the
genie back into the bottle.
So data breaches, and data
loss, are a huge concern,
and you don't want to lose
the trust of your customers.
Thankfully, VPC
Service Controls also
applies to this
particular scenario,
so exfiltration
attempts can be blocked.
So just some key takeaways here.
The VPC Service
Controls basically
helps prevent forms of
unauthorized data movement,
and that applies, regardless
of if you control the projects,
or not.
The key here is this
helps you prevent
that activity from occurring
in the first place.
Now at Target, we have ways
to detect data exfiltration.
But once you detect that
data has been exfiltrated,
it's a little too late.
So with a combination
of VPC Service Controls
and our detective methods,
we feel really comfortable
with our security posture.
And the great part is, this
works, regardless of who
or what it's trying
to move this data.
So whether you're trying
to do it on purpose,
or maybe take a little
shortcut at work because you're
about to approach a
deadline, it'll still work.
Next I want to talk to you
about the interconnect options
that we use.
Now I'm going to
start with Cloud VPN,
because when we
migrated to GCP in 2017,
Cloud VPN was the first
interconnect mechanism
that we've used.
So we've been using it
for over two years now.
Now the great part
about Cloud VPN
is it's relatively inexpensive.
It's pretty quick
to set up, and it
can scale to some pretty
reasonable performance.
There are some drawbacks.
If you have really
high throughput needs,
or if you have extremely
high demands for reliability,
but by and large it works great.
Now importantly,
VPN will typically
traverse the public internet.
And that means that there
can be some issues that will
impact your VPN connectivity.
So for example, let's say
that the red provider here
has some sort of
issue with their edge,
and their routes are withdrawn.
Now this can cause a bit of
temporary connectivity issues
if your traffic was pathed
over the red provider.
You can also have issues
upstream or downstream,
with capacity, because the
provider withdrew their routes.
And finally, there's a scenario
that occurs sometimes a little
too often, and these
are route hijacks.
Now these don't necessarily
have to be malicious,
but they can still impact the
stability of your VPN tunnels.
So all said, cloud VPN actually
works pretty well for us
in non-commerce,
because we don't have
any synchronous requirements.
However, we do need to
have higher availability
in the commerce environment.
And that is because we
have synchronous callbacks
for our data centers.
Any interruptions
in those callbacks
prevents checkout
from working properly,
which impacts our revenue.
So we wanted to explore
a different solution.
We moved to partner
interconnect.
And what we do here is we
operate a router at our edge.
Our router connects
to an ISP, who
happens to be one of the
partner interconnect providers,
and we have a private, redundant
path that avoids the internet,
and meets back up with
Google at its peering edge,
and goes into the VPC.
So this is really
helpful, in terms
of maintaining a very, very
high stability environment
for critical connectivity.
As Shubhikia mentioned,
it's scalable as well,
so you can scale between
50 megabits per second
to 10 gigabits per second.
And if you're looking to
provision things really quickly
and you have high
bandwidth needs,
you can actually provision this
a little quicker than direct
interconnect in some cases.
Now just briefly I want
to talk about Cloud Armor,
and what I have
here on the screen
is an example flow
from our guests,
calling all the way into some
resources that we have in GCP.
So what happens here
is our guest will
call to one of our
digital properties,
and that call will go
through our CDM, Fastly.
What will happen here is
we'll traverse the CDM.
There's a number of
things that happen here.
Web application firewalls
or WAFs, routing,
caching, and so on.
And eventually that
request will make it down
to our load balancers,
through Cloud Armor,
and into the backend instance.
Once that traffics there,
we'll generate a response,
and it'll go all the way
back out to our guest.
Now the reason
this works is we've
configured Cloud
Armor to allow traffic
in from Fastly, and a few
other approved sources.
Our guests, though,
aren't the only thing that
are out there on the internet.
So you can imagine there's
some malicious actors out there
running port scanners and
various other reconnaissance
things.
And we don't actually want
them to hit our services,
and they really don't need
to in the first place.
In fact, we only want Fastly,
our CDN, our data centers,
and our headquarters locations,
to be able to hit these load
balancers.
So when they send traffic,
it hits the load balancer,
and we're actually
able to see this.
It's logged in Stackdriver.
But the traffic is blocked
by a Cloud Armor policy,
and those requests never make
it to the backend instances.
In either case,
we see these logs,
and we can export them to our
SIEM for security analysis.
All right.
Next up, really
quickly, I just want
to talk about our use cases
for VPC Flow Logs and firewall
logs.
Zach did a great job
running through these.
There's a lot of rich
annotations and metadata
that you get with these.
But what I thought I'd do is
show you a sanitized firewall
log example, in case
you haven't seen
one of these before, and just
talk through it a little bit.
So what we can see in
this particular example
is we have an instance that's
running a service project,
and it seems to be
a little suspicious.
And notably what we
can see happening
here is this instance,
is connecting
to an IP address that's
out on the public internet.
And it's using protocol 17 in
port 53, so this is UDP 53 DNS.
Now in situations
like this, DNS could
be used as a command and
control mechanism for a botnet,
for example.
So this isn't really great.
Now the good news is, we've
actually blocked this traffic
with an explicit
egress denial rule
that we've set at a
really low priority.
So we have some other
rules that mandate
having an allow rule in place
before that traffic can egress,
so we're protected here.
But it's really
helpful to know this.
We take this
information, and we use
Cloud Pub/Sub to send it to
our on-prem SIEM for analysis
and alerting.
We also can use other syncs and
exports, like BigQuery or GCS,
and we actually export these
to GCS, as well, for long term
retention, and in
case we need to do
any sort of forensic analysis.
So looking forward
really quickly,
I just want to run through
a couple of things.
Over the next year,
Target is really
looking forward to some
enhancements with VPC Service
Controls.
There's a piece that
we didn't touch on yet,
called
restricted.GoogleAPIs.com.
It's a /30 net block.
Now the real advantage
to using this,
beyond being able to restrict
what APIs you can actually talk
to, is it's a /30 net block.
So it's a much
smaller address space
to manage than the
19 net blocks that
represent Google's public APIs.
So it ultimately results in
a reduction in firewall rules
and routes, and other
various management overhead.
Cloud NAT.
Now managing NATs is toilsome.
We do it, and they can
be difficult to scale.
So we're really looking
forward to Cloud NAT.
But today we install software on
our NATs that inspects traffic,
and that isn't available
yet in Cloud NAT.
So we're looking forward to some
potential developments there.
And then finally, Google's
managed TLS certificates.
Target operates over 200
HTTPS load balancers,
and that is a lot of
certificates to keep track of.
So we're going to
have some discussions
with our internal security
teams later this year,
and see if we can move to these.
Now before we move
to Q&A, I just
wanted to give a shameless plug.
A colleague, Nicole,
and I, will be
giving a presentation
tomorrow that
discusses a little
more in detail
some of the architecture,
specifically around shared VPC,
VPC peering, and firewall rules
that involve service accounts.
So if you're
interested in seeing
this in a little more detail,
please join us tomorrow.
It should be a lot of fun.
And I know that
conferences are busy,
so we're going to do Q&A
in a little bit here.
If you have any
Target-specific questions
and you need to run
to your next session,
this email address will be
active for the next couple
weeks.
So feel free to shoot
me an email address,
or shoot me an email, and I'll
try to answer it as best I can.
And with that, I'll hand
things back over to Shubhikia
to wrap things up.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]